en fait vous avez fait du cinéma ces
dernières années pour pour souffler
parce que c'est ma vous dites c'est un
peu une planque quoi c'est un peu des
vacances c'est dur de dire ça par
rapport au métier d'acteur qu'un métier
difficile mais par rapport à la chanson
et le fait de pas faire partie d'un
groupe d'être tout seul à assumer tout -
les responsabilités de d'être au cinéma
de d'enfiler le costume d'un autre
personnage de laisser sa vie du côté et
la pression allait plus pour le metteur
en scène au cinéma
donc je trouve ouais c'est se reposant
certainement pas fini et puis donc fait
pas mal de films et puis un jour ça ça
commence à vous à vous démange et quand
même cette idée de recommencer à chanter
pilote de l'asa quand même depuis trois
ans et puis vous avez fait un bébé
donc ça a été quand même assez long la
maturation de cet album les 3 4 ans et
là après roda-gil après langolff après
kravitz après gainsbourg vous demander
avec qui travailler vouliez pas d'un
disque prêt à chanter sur l'habitude on
vous apportez des chansons et puis vous
choisissiez là vous voulez vraiment vous
impliquer beaucoup plus dans la dans la
production du disque nom fabrique
alors un jour êtes dans un studio comme
ça vous mettez devant un piano vous
jouez avec trois doigts et puis ça plaît
à vos copains vous dites je joue très
mal mais ça suffit pour écrire des
chansons
vous pouvez pas que les gens qui sont
autour de vous à ce moment là ils vous
disent que c'est bien parce que c'est
vos copains d'abord c'était c'était
juste une personne et puis moi cette
personne n'a pas dit c'est bien je les
ai mis sur son visage donc oui je vois
j'ai cru que c'était censé être chaud
enfin notre exemple et même et ça c'est
très content et si vous avez été touché
non seulement vous avez écrit des
chansons non plus et produit l'album
une autre partie avec matthieu chedid et
puis j'ai enfin il ya une plage où tu
veux en venir tirer là concrètement
pourtant je veux utilise deux balances
pense que c'est une question je les
avais plein gens n'ont pas quand même si
je veux pouvoir me tuer oui bien sûr
mais vous dites c'est monde dise quoi
vous êtes mis au centre du dispositif
c'est ça que je veux dire oui oui c'est
non si c'est vrai je n'ai pas fait tout
seul mais mais si ça devait conduire
parler de mon univers et des choses des
choses qui me touchent
non je veux savoir sable on s'était un
peu présomptueux c'est comme les acteurs
qui se mettent à vouloir réaliser des
films ça que je vais dire est ce que
c'est pas un peu présomptueux contenu
une chanteuse talentueuse certes
évidemment mais dont j'avoue de se dire
je peux aussi écrire je peux aussi
produire ça en fait je joue mais je me
suis pas dit que je pouvais le faire
je les fais mais j'avais j'avais
beaucoup plus de dons bien on va écouter
à quoi ça ressemble
mini 12
un corner
non
ça
mardi
sachez dernier c'est que fait la ville
la fisa cette idée de manosque et le
texte j'ai créé la musique c'est exact
vous bravo alors je retire tout ce que
je dis il a participé d'ailleurs johnny
depp on écrit de musique ensemble et
puis il a joué dessus sur un titre
ouais vous êtes content tout va bien dit
dick we et une fois que je terminais à
un tas de choses qu'on a envie de
changer mais il ya moins il faut
s'arrêter